حسنًا ، تم اتخاذ القرار في أقصر وقت ممكن
حان الوقت لتنفيذ مجموعة من التدابير ل
تحويل الدفع ، فلنبدأ بهذا من
دفع تحويل الغاز الطبيعي لدينا
توريد الغاز الطبيعي بذلك
دعا الدول غير الصديقة ل
روبل روسي
[موسيقى]
كيف حالك خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
كما تعلم ، لم تكن هناك دول غربية قريبة
اتخذت قرارات غير شرعية وقرارات بشأن ذلك
ما يسمى بتجميد الأصول الروسية
و
فشل الغرب الجماعي في الواقع
خط تحت موثوقية عملاتهم
[موسيقى]
في نفس الوقت ، أود أن أؤكد ذلك
سوف تستمر روسيا في الإمداد دون قيد أو شرط
الغاز الطبيعي حسب الحجم و
بالأسعار
تعليم ثابت لك
العقود الموقعة مسبقًا
[موسيقى]
أطلب من بنك روسيا مع
الحكومة في غضون أسبوع
تحديد الإجراء لمثل هذا